ben remember when the mainstream media
falsely claimed these border agents were
whipping haitian migrants attempting to
cross our border illegally well
those agents are now suing the biden
administration and a new op-ed says the
white house is actually on their side
here to react tom allman former acting
ice director tom you have seen these
frivolous lawsuits first hand what's
really going on here
well first of all you notice these
groups aren't waiting for an
investigation a conclusion to the
investigation
and where is that the secretary promised
that months ago the reason there isn't a
conclusion to investigation because the
investigators are in a tough spot
because the secretary the president and
vice president already said these agents
did something wrong and and the real
investigators would say well they didn't
the policy is clear look i started my
career in the border patrol i know the
rules of engagement i've seen the video
these officers did nothing wrong they
did their jobs they use the horses the
same they use the horse the same way
they use horses in times square for
crowd control they did their job the
only one the only one that did anything
wrong with the haitian migrants they
entered the country illegally which is a
crime it's a misdemeanor they ignored a
verbal command from a federal officer
which is a felony but these groups are
going to sue they're not going to
investigation to end because it's going
to conclude there's nothing happening
they're going to use the statements of
the president saying he's appalled and
these agents will pay the statements
from the vice president who said it was
a racist issue the statements from the
secretary homeland security who says he
was appalled and that he can't believe
borbacho trained horses to attack
children and this is the same secretary
says he wants a fair independent review
investigation well too late he already
mother muddy the waters by vilifying the
men and women horseback this is about
lining the pockets of these advocacy
advocacy groups and open border groups
that the white house supports it's about
getting some sort of status for the
haitian migrants because there's a
policy if someone is in the country been
ordered deported but they're suing the
government you can't remove them you
can't remove them because they're mental
litigation and many times these lawsuits
will make the government bring people
engines into the united states to do
litigation against the government
there's a lot of
bad intentions in this lawsuit so that's
exactly what this is about lining their
pockets and getting some sort of uh
reward for those who broke our laws into
the country lately
tom we got about 45 seconds left look i
understand it from the perspective of
these open borders advocacy groups this
is what they want we don't agree with it
but they're fighting for their side i
understand it from the side of the
haitian migrants they want to come to
the u.s again don't agree with the way
they're doing it but understand it what
i can't wrap my head around at all is
the federal government's number one job
is to really enforce the nation's
borders and it's also to defend the rule
of law in both instances they're not
doing it by helping the people bringing
suit against the government if this
author's implication is correct what say
you
100 agree with what you just said these
lawsuits send them bad messages because
they're hoping the government settles
these cases out of court because of the
nuisance factors they don't want to sign
all these attorneys to litigate when i
was a nice director i refused to settle
out of court i said if we did nothing
wrong
our attorneys will litigate
and because we're not going to give a
freebie to an advocacy group that wants
to do nothing but line our pockets this
administration has refused to enforce
our immigration laws on the border and
this is one of the results of not
enforcing the laws rewarding those who
break our laws rather than have some
sort of consequence or deterrence to
breaking the law
in a year of head scratchers this one
may even top the list i don't get this
tom homan thank you for your insight
this morning sir we appreciate it ben
over to you